JAMES GRIME: OK, so 42 is
maybe not such a special
number in mathematics,
but a very special
number in nerd culture.
PHIL MORIARTY: Good.
Good, good, good.
Did you want to do something
with 42?
JAMES GRIME: Yes.
So you take a piece of paper.
It's very thin.
Let's fold this in half.
Fold it in half again.
Imagine you can keep doing this,
and in reality you can't
keep doing this.
But imagine you can keep folding
it in half, and each
time you do, it will double
in thickness.
And if you fold it 42 times,
that's enough to reach from
the Earth to the moon.
You notice when 42 turns up,
you keep noticing it.
But that's not really all that
remarkable, since any two
digit number will turn up one
hundredth of the time.
GERARDO ADESSO: Today we're in
my office, and we are talking
about numbers.
And when I was asked about
thinking about the number, I
just realized that there is a
number that I see every day
when I enter my office,
and this number is 42.
Because we are in this
office, B42.
JAMES GRIME: 42 is maybe not
such a special number in
mathematics, but a very special
number in nerd culture.
42 is the answer to life, the
universe, and everything.
GERARDO ADESSO: If you'll now
go on Google, the answer to
life, the universe,
and everything.
So Google calculator gives
you as an answer, 42.
PHIL MORIARTY: 42 is the answer
to life, the universe,
and everything.
I am a huge, huge, huge
Douglas Adams fan.
My favorite book is The Hitch
Hiker's Guide To The Galaxy.
All my favorite books are the
trilogy of five books that
makes up Douglas Adams' work in
terms of a character called
Arthur Dent.
JAMES GRIME: The author Douglas
Adams, a great comedy
writer, wrote first a radio
series called the Hitch
Hiker's Guide To The Galaxy.
In the show they built a super
computer, a giant super
computer to work out the meaning
of life, the universe,
and everything.
And after millions of years, it
decided that the meaning of
life, the universe, and
everything was 42.
PHIL MORIARTY: At which point
the people who programmed the
computer and built the
computer were rather
disappointed, but the computer
quite rightly said, well,
what's the question?
And they said it's the
ultimate question.
The ultimate question of life,
the universe, and everything.
But what's the question?
Which is, I think is a
completely valid thing.
So then the idea was to build
a supercomputer which would
calculate the ultimate
question.
And the supercomputer was Earth,
and we formed part-- or
humans formed part of that
organic framework.
JAMES GRIME: You've
ruined the ending!
PHIL MORIARTY: Oh, yeah, if you
really haven't listened
to, or watched, or read the
Hitch Hiker's Guide To The
Galaxy books, you
haven't lived.
So go out and get them now.
JAMES GRIME: A perhaps
slightly embarrassing
confession is that I used to
be involved with the Hitch
Hiker's Guide To The
Galaxy fan club.
And I use to help
run it, briefly.
Just a few years ago when the
film came out, I remember it
was quite an exciting time.
I don't see them anymore.
It's a shame, but I know more
things about 42 than I
really ought to.
GERARDO ADESSO: This
number, 42, is said
to be a pronic number.
JAMES GRIME: A what, sorry?
GERARDO ADESSO: A
pronic number.
JAMES GRIME: What
does that mean?
GERARDO ADESSO: I can
write it for you.
So a pronic number is a number
which is obtained as the
multiplication of two
successive integers.
So for instance, in the
case of 42, 42 is
equal to 6 times 7.
These are one after the other,
and any number which is like
this is called pronic.
For instance, 2 times 3,
3 times 4, and so on.
JAMES GRIME: Douglas Adams,
I think chose this number
because it kind of has
a funny sound.
40, all those O's, 42,
it's a funny sound.
PHIL MORIARTY: Again, if you go
on the web, and if you read
some of the articles about 42,
there are arguments ranging
from, well actually it's 101010
in binary, which is a
nice binary number.
And in fact, in the television
program that flashes up.
When they say 42, you
see the binary.
JAMES GRIME: You'll find 42
comes up a lot in comedy and
other shows, partly because of
Douglas Adams and because he
used it, but partly because
it's just a funny sound.
GERARDO ADESSO: Then there is
another interesting property,
which is slightly more
complicated about this number.
And it is the fact that it's
defined to be a primary
pseudoperfect number.
JAMES GRIME: A what?
GERARDO ADESSO: A primary
pseudoperfect number.
JAMES GRIME: Go on, what
does that mean?
GERARDO ADESSO: OK, so first of
all, you have to find out
what are the prime
factors of 42.
OK, so write down 42 as 2 times
3, which is 6 times 7.
So these are its
prime factors.
Primary to the perfect number
is such that the sum of the
inverse of each prime factor
plus the sum of the inverse of
the number itself is 1.
1 over 2 plus 1 over 3 plus 1
over 7, and these are the sum
of the inverses of each
prime factor.
Then plus 1 over the
number itself.
If you work out this
calculation, you can put
everything under the
common denominator.
The result is one.
There are not so many numbers
that have this property.
The next one after 42
is, I think 1,806.
And then you immediately go
to very huge numbers.
So it appears like
any [INAUDIBLE]
property, but it's not.
JAMES GRIME: The story
is he sat--
he wrote it in his garden, he
sat in his back garden.
He thought, what number
should I choose?
It should be a sort of
smallish number.
It should be a sort
of boring number.
42 will do, and he picked 42.
PHIL MORIARTY: There's also
arguments that 6 times 9, if
you look at that problem
in base 13, out
pops the number 42.
All these mad, mad things that
Douglas Adams himself said
were absolutely bonkers.
He said he chose 42 because
it's a funny number.
He thought it was
a funny number.
GERARDO ADESSO: And then there
is another, for instance
another one which
42 belongs to.
It's the sequence of
harshad numbers.
Harshad is written like this.
So what is a harshad number?
It's a number that
is divisible by
the sum of its digits.
So you have 42, take 4 plus 2.
This is 6.
And 42 is divisible by 6.
So any number with
this property is
called harshad number.
JAMES GRIME: Do you think
it's a funny number?
PHIL MORIARTY: Oh,
I don't know.
If it's an interesting one.
Would I have gone for 42?
I don't know.
What number is funnier
than 42?
71?
I don't know.
68?
GERARDO ADESSO: If you're very
bright in mathematics, and you
participate in the International
Olympiads of
Mathematics, and the total mark
to achieve the perfect
score is set at 42.
JAMES GRIME: Is that a
coincidence, or do you think
someone did that on purpose?
GERARDO ADESSO: Well,
this I don't know.
We need to ask the people who
are involved in these
committees.
But before Douglas Adams, that
was already quite a lot of
attention on this number from
works by Lewis Carroll.
And you know, mathematicians,
they are known to have a
particular taste for
recurrences and
nerdiness, so to say.
So it may be that this was
chosen on purpose.
But I don't know.
JAMES GRIME: In the fan club
magazine, they would have a
column all about where
people have seen
the number 42 recently.
And it was a bit of fun,
except for one guy.
He took it quite seriously.
He actually thought there
was a mystical meaning
behind the number 42.
Genuinely thought there was.
And he used to go through the
phone book and look for
multiples of 42 in peoples'
phone numbers.
He used to find a multiple of
6, find a multiple of 7,
multiply them together
and go oh, look.
It's a multiple of 42.
How amazing.
It really isn't that remarkable
if you look for
things like that.
PHIL MORIARTY: Soon as I see
it, there's an instant
resonance there when I see 42.
And in fact, one of the
experiments I want to do,
we're working with taking
a silicon surface.
Surface like this, where we
put hydrogen atoms on it.
And then we take a tip of a
scanning probe microscope and
remove the hydrogen atoms
one at a time.
And one thing I really want
to do is put 42 on
a surface in atoms.
JAMES GRIME: Fox Mulder's
apartment in the X-Files was
apartment 42, which may be a
reference to Hitch Hiker.